hi I'm Nicolas P with reason TV we're at
Freedom Fest in Las Vegas and right now
we're talking with Mark Klugman he's a
an advisor to the president of Honduras
he's advised a number of other Latin
American and North American presidents
including people like Ronald Reagan and
the senior Bush who he wrote speeches
for and worked with you were very much
in the Charter City the free city
movement in Honduras which has had some
setbacks talk about what's going on now
and why people who are interested in
seeing a city that comes together based
on you know market ideas is going
forward great thanks yeah in Honduras
there is a reform to the Constitution
that actually makes it possible to
create a jurisdiction like Hong Kong now
I don't use the word City for the same
reason someone was writing a screenplay
doesn't say I'm writing an oscar-winning
movie no you're writing a screenplay the
market will decide if it becomes an
oscar-winning movie a blockbuster what
we need to do a create jurisdictions and
I call them Leap zones le AP legal
economic administrative political these
are not special economic zones there are
3,000 special economic zones in the
world that's great it's a chair with one
lake you need to have a judicial system
that is credible you don't get rule of
law you need to have an executive you
don't have to pay bribes to get things
done and we're the police that actually
provides security not corruption and you
need to have a system of governance that
is more than a sandcastle where it's not
gonna be washed away through demagoguery
these districts or jurisdictions rather
are they geographical or are they
affiliative I mean how do they work and
when will they actually be coming online
in Honduras that's a great question
the the initial stages they are they are
geographical areas I think in the future
chapter 7 once you go through the
various iterations of it you perfectly
well could create virtual spaces the
same way by election you guys I wanted
to be elect you know the you know
subchapter S but at this stage these are
territorial the Congress of Honduras has
the faculty to designate an unlimited
number of special zones right now there
are two communities in Honduras
we're the local population has asked to
have it placed on the ballot in November
a few months from now if it will be
designated that there there are area
where they live will be designated as a
special jurisdiction over so so we can
look to the elections in November to see
if this stuff immediately comes online
let's say they win you know the two
places to get it you have lief
jurisdictions what happens next
well what happens next is really
exciting because what you've done is
this area is now semi-autonomous it's
separated from the political regime and
in in the in the capital there is a
Board of Trustees in essence which
provides the buffer and the guarantees
of stability under rule of law you have
into the written to the constitutional
law that there's a cap on taxation these
are low tax low regulation regimes and
the most exciting part is a page is
being taken out of the success of Lee
Kuan Yew or Hong Kong for that matter
which is Lee Kuan Yew in Singapore yeah
exactly both of those jurisdictions Hong
Kong and Singapore when Singapore came
to independence in 1965 Lee Kuan Yew
said I need to offer investors and my
population world-class justice and to
create good institutions requires time
that exceeds a human lifespan so how do
you do it what I call institutional
leapfrogging
you say okay where in the world does
that already exist well at London the
Judicial Committee of the Privy Council
members of the House of Lords with wigs
they're not going to be taking bribes
from a businessman in Singapore or a
foreign investor doing business there
that will be my Supreme Court so said
Lee Kuan Yew when he kept it that way
for 20 years Hong Kong throughout the
British period the same thing was
British courts when Hong Kong is handed
over to China it doesn't get integrated
into the Chinese judicial system they
create a new Court again through
institutional leapfrogging let me ask
you as a final point you know Lee Kuan
Yew and Singapore it's not necessary I
mean it's a great was a great place to
invest maybe not a great place to live
especially if you have kind of wacky
ideas about lifestyle choice what is
what's likely to happen in Honduras in
these jurisdictions will you know what
what kinds of places will they be like
will they be more like Sam Francis
or more like you know I'm trying to
think of you know a city where you know
it's a you know or is it gonna be more
like Riyadh I guess I wouldn't compare
them to either okay it I think will be
very I think they'll be Honduran because
Honduras is a country where you have a
population and for many people their
best option is to leave they risk their
lives to do it there's a train called
the Beast and they get on this train
which will take them up through
Guatemala a very high casualty right
people lose their legs they fall off the
train then they get into Mexico you may
be captured by the Zetas a criminal drug
organization you're a woman they may put
you forcibly in a brothel if you're a
man they may turn you into a into a drug
mule
it's a very danger but when people reach
that level of desperation they wait a
minute what if there's one more option
what if in your own country there's a
space where there'll be transparency
under rule of law it'll be a classical
liberal arrangement where they'll be
safety and freedom and I think the first
requirement of a special zone in a place
where so much of the populations in
precarious situations is not to fulfill
the imagination of programmers who are
living in Silicon Valley I think the
first requirement is it needs to fulfill
the needs of the people who are in
Honduras because right now they're not
having very good options and this is
transformative and once Honduras does
this the other countries of Central
America experience a tremendous
competitive requirement to copy it now
what we know from the experience with
China with the special economic zones is
once you create these tiny spaces within
the larger territory these tiny spaces
eventually overwhelmed the large
territory George Gilder brilliantly said
prior to the handover of Hong Kong to
China from the British he said Oh 1997
that will be the year that Hong Kong
takes over China and of course he was
right and here is an opportunity where
by using very small pieces of land we
can transform very large areas and give
people millions of people the chances
for a better life with more freedom well
hopefully well you know in a year we'll
be talking about these places in
Honduras that have become a shining city
on a hill that maybe Americans will
learn something from we've been talking
with Mark Klugman he's an adviser to the
president of Honduras and he's working
on bringing lead
jurisdictions to a country that needs
more freedom just as we all do mark
thanks for talking with us for reason TV
I'm Nicolas P